alter meist ich habe die eier ich
studiere hast ist weg
minecraft hero immer auch mit konkreter
hallo bist du schon einmal gegangen nein
aber ich sehe gerade zwei leute sind
schon leute drauf und wir haben gerade
bei twitter gepostet thema und es hat
mir ein cooles team ausgesuchter müssen
zwei leute durch gefälschte motegi ich
meinte rettig 100 euro werden es in
trier und laut pilz eine gefahr
eine gefahr angreifen rewe statt inc wer
die stadt ja ich gehe ich habe mich
gleich an greiss wunder angreifen
partner auf mächtig koppelt angreifen
angreifen
hier ist news angreifen so zackig dass
wir alle meine sachen weg tue ich auch
gerade und ich bin fertig ich bin auch
auf dem weg ich bin sofort da heißt ich
könnte ab jetzt attac man mit nur 1 ist
sauber starten wo bist du denn da in
meinem haus ich kann daher keine blöcke
bei der abbau darfst dich rein worten
ich habe ja keine walkers water ich habe
keine spitzhacke dabei welcher meine
erste wieder zu so kommt er mit
du wirst hier ab jetzt wirklich selber
weiterhelfen müssen weil geht bei diesen
block i ab also ja dazwischen genau die
noch in den zweiten durchgang
gib mir die beiden blöcke und genau und
da rein
diese folge ist die gestartet beim
abholen muss auch geradeaus gehen weil
das unsichtbare block nicht weiter
verraten
und jetzt
das ich wo ich hin muss folge mehrfach
vielleicht ist der brauchen statt rot
das kann auch sein ich will auf jeden
fall mit marie wichtiger hafen
ich schaue jetzt hier ich bin wie gesagt
da ich glaube der ist hier nicht die
musik ist dann aus
der scheint hier nicht zu sein ich habe
es nicht dabei ist ist dabei ich habe
ein bisschen letzten dabei ja ich gehe
öfter 32 habe ich alles aus dem
aussortieren aber ich hab dafür paulsons
damit kann man mit vielleicht ist er
doch irgendwo als hätte man schon
gesehen das gute ist dann mit dem
flugzeug unterwegs ist der hat so eine
komische länder einstellung dass erst
spieler angezeigt werden und danach die
blöcke geladen werden das heißt wir
hätten ihn wahrscheinlich so inmitten
von nichts stehen sehen und danach wäre
es die landschaft um ihr umgespannt ja
dann lass mein stadtrat vorbeigucken ich
hab ihr spiegelt dabei dann gehe ich
eben statt rot ja und ich sage ich es
schade dass er noch die blaue farbe
trägt ja so statt rot wir bauen was
friedlich so was gibt es hier nicht
wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen schreiben
aber unsere städte sind im krieg er kann
er wieder beleben aber pink ist hässlich
es gibt ja wie der belebung
ich finde die stadt roth ich auch wo
bist du was bei dem treffen ich habe
keinen flugsteig man sich gerade grenzen
mehr
mega uncool der jameda und kohle ist nur
pink also ich bin jetzt bei den schiffen
denn auch bei den schiffen bin jetzt bei
simons haus und ich hab ich gesehen wenn
ein full scale ist oder wie oft ich habe
auch full scale
er ist ein bisschen stadtmitte glaube
ich nur zwei gegen mich ich bin bei ich
sehe dich jetzt müsste doch so wirklich
drauf gehen wahrscheinlich bei opel sein
haus wo ist das das da vorne mit den
sachen radio war drauf ach du ich weiß
nicht wen ich vorproduzieren nicht lang
schnacken kopp in nacken jeder von uns
hat die situation bei den anschlägen
nicht diskutieren
wenn wir auf dem server werden droht
prinz hat auch echt ganz andere sache
nicht und flugzeug steigt und ins haus
erst mal mit bogen erstmal mit bogen ich
hab keinen bogen ich hab
ich glaube die sind in die portale
gegangen oder das ticketportal auch
benutzen aber vielleicht hat mit dem
handel
find ich irgendwie hallo oder distanz an
gehalt das geht auch nicht irgendwo
verstecken
ich glaube dass die reingegangen sind
die am portal zustand blau und das ist
außerhalb unserer reichweite darf das
auch abbauen solches abbauen
wo ist denn das hast du speziell mit dem
bleiburger gebäude durch meinen portal
abbauen nicht von außen ist denn ich hab
noch gar nicht gesehen ich bin jetzt
wieder an statt brot weil ich sehe ich
gar nicht mich ja jetzt wieder okay gut
dass das von hier aus abbauen weil es
ist ja das wird mal machen aber ich weiß
nicht dürfen das wirklich machen
natürlich ich bin nur der befehls
ausführende du bist der befehlsgeber ok
abgebaut
du hast gesagt ich darf abbauen
das ist wenn du mir sagst du dich nach
den regeln das ist genauso als wenn du
die polizei wärs und ich frage wir bei
der polizei darf diese menschen umringt
und die polizei sagt ja da absolut
gesetzt ist das erlaubt und marie sann
ist die polizei zurück schuld erlaubt
wickeltechnik ist es erlaubt habe die
regeln geschrieben mit aber es ist als
schon mega soziale du es ist auf seinem
mist gewachsen du hast gesagt ich total
ab habe ich nicht gesagt es ist das ist
genauso über den nazis du hast aussagen
können nein was gesagt war die portale
nein das möchte ich nicht schlafen
ihr habt auf ein nichts kaputt gemacht
hier kann auch nicht sein ding durch
dribbelt so okay aber ich glaube ja
also thema hat wenn du jetzt ein ganz
ganz schweren unfall hätte es also auch
so gesehen hat auch wie viel davon von
joe kaeser falls ihr einen schweren
unfall hat würdet ihr dann eure youtube
karriere auf eis legen oder beenden
ich verstehe die frage insofern nicht
weil wenn ich beispielsweise einen
schweren unfall hätte wir gehen davon
aus dass ich noch meine geistigen
fähigkeiten behalte was wenn du dich
paket mit meinen aluminium in diesem
alter eben rein sonst wäre die frage
sinnlos das heißt meine geistigen
fähigkeiten muss ich ja irgendwo
behalten aber beispielsweise ich
verliere mind oder ich bin im rollstuhl
saß ich kann nicht mehr gehen ja dann
nein ich habe ja mit youtube angefangen
weil es ein hobby ist und
dementsprechend wird dich
selbstverständlich denke ich mit youtube
weitermachen also dass zumindest mein
ding wieso sollte ich mir wenn ich meine
beine schon verloren habe diese soll ich
das damit am besten noch aufhören was
mir am meisten spaß macht das ist
unlogisch
ja das würde ich mich auch sagen und
zwar so komischen die wie in
fondsmanager
na gut natürlich auch sagen und zwar
egal wie schlimm sage ich mal ein unfall
ist youtube kann man eigentlich immer
weiter laufen lassen es ist egal ob ihm
dieser und verlässt außer wenn man jetzt
irgendwie ich würde mal sagen wenn man
jetzt im rollstuhl sitzt kann man es
immer noch weitermachen
aber wenn man jetzt natürlich irgendwie
eine geistige behinderung hat dann ist
es natürlich schon doof das ist dann ein
bisschen schwieriger das wofür sie gut
gesagt hätte dann hat man verpackt aber
das wollen wir nicht hoffen dass so was
passiert passiert ausgabe noch mal
checken du ich bin gerade am bauen hier
natürlich alle dass alle alle zwei
minuten ein reihenhaus abgebaut
die karate ich bin sofort fällig
ich bin da so hasst das aluminium
reingepackt oder noch jünger war
hannelore blöd von dir das denn was da
dein ingalls reingepackt obwohl er noch
im geschmolzenes eisen renova aber
glücklicherweise vermischt sich das
nicht dass jetzt am 15 die von mir aus
kommt also lasst das alte name einer
kiste und dann kommt ein aluminium okay
ich habe diese knöpfe gemacht ja wie
findest du okay ja ich finde das sehr
cool
das passt auch dass diese knöpfe sind
besser dieser schalter da oben drauf und
die analogie bedient das auch ganz gut
im bett wirklich denkt man da noch ein
mann irgendwie den denn wie heißt er
denn hier dieser einer der jetzt grad
abgetreten ist
ich bin in der politik so unwissend also
mich bloß nicht fragen wie heißt in
dieser typ det abgedankt hat nicht wulff
der andere im bahnhof ich gregor gysi
dieser also ist er ab jetzt ist auf
jeden fall konkreter der politik
beauftragte hier in der stadt
ich weiß ja nie mal wieder so hasst das
jetzt zu wissen ablesbar folge die warte
ich ab dann als tester dann lade ich ein
bisschen lieber wollte sie nur eine
kleine kiste eine kiste wo ich jetzt
erstmal
ein paar sachen rein packe die ich mir
zum bauen einfach hole genau war das
auch kraß die einfach so respekt vor uns
hat man sich einfach abgewischt ich
glaube die sind wieder da ja du aber
jetzt packe ich dinge ist wir haben
einen dummen fehler gemacht ich kann
auch sagen welchen wir haben unseren
namen gesehen wenn ich da jetzt aber
hingehe mit wir club of destruction und
zehn ändert dann ist man zwar nicht
unsichtbare mein name ist nicht sichtbar
was mach ich jetzt
ich habe spiegelt dabei einen pfeil ein
schwert alles dabei ich werde bei ja
hast du einen unsichtbarkeit machen denn
unsichtbarkeit markt naja wie du kannst
du bitte vorgehen ich bin schon in
stadtroda
ich bin der stadtrat ich frag nur wieso
9 statt rot aktiviert
die frage ist jetzt natürlich hast du
nach dem kader aus
denn was sein sollte die frage ist nur
wie so zeigt er mir jetzt nur 30
sekunden an obwohl ich weder habe
mehrere ändert werden kev rauscht ein
bisschen aber so schlimm ich bin schon
das kann ich mit dem haus ist
die stärkste vielleicht läuft einer von
ihnen erzählen
siehst du meinen namen kommen ja ich seh
dich ich sehe dich selig da kann das war
einer von denen aber sie ist mit meinen
namen ja wie du bist ein bisschen anders
jetzt immer noch genau gleich wie
verarschen
weil sie nicht direkt daran gemacht ok
wenn altrheinarm jehle gefressen wusste
ich was kann ich jetzt das haus wo bist
du denn capcom zu mir ich hab keinen
flug zauberstab umschlägt und jetzt
wieder anstatt pink rettet den stadtpark
rot bedeutet ihr haben die schwache zum
bauen benutzt können einfach gucken ob
sich irgendwas tut so bei mäßig oder die
sinne statt geld weil hier ist ja was
ist eigentlich wenn man jetzt durch das
portal geht du ich will nicht
durchgehend alter meist ich habe die
eier studie heißt es weg
das portal funktioniert auch in die
richtung l ich ja meine richtung ich
dachte ich komme inzwischen dimension
läuft für teenager habe ich eigentlich
schon unser zug vorgesehen
wo ist denn unsere stadt von hier aus
alter behinderter da ja und b da dann
gewinnen sie landen schau mal hier vorne
beim torabschluss vorgesehen ja klar wer
denkt schon gezeigt voller sozialen
jetlag hab ich gewartet und dann nimmt
er mir den genuss diese fünf blöcke zu
setzen
ja es aber sehr hübsch finde ich hab'
ich teuer gekauft und man wird dich
niemals setzen
ich war jetzt endlich mal bauen und zwar
mussten jetzt mit inventar so aufbauen
als wenn ich wirklich bauen will genau
1000 auf als wenn du bauen willst ja so
lasse der regen läuft aus das ein
bisschen an so für viele ihn und so so
ist eine aluminium ist hier drin hätte
ich ja besser leben ist ein stück brot
zwar ein bisschen weiter haben sie holz
und redstone behinderung ich kann es dir
alles von mir nehmen was du willst also
nicht sortiert ne scheiße hier sortiert
ich lieber ein machtpoker menschen
präsentiert so hab ich denn nicht noch
ich hätte von aluminium
so wird mal hardcase der mtk ist ach das
ist einfach nur so aluminium
so ist es raus natürlich war vier
komponenten
ok es wirklich müssen zurück wenn der
sound auf null ist die sehen und haben
wir aber geschrieben aber die greife er
nicht an
ja das sowieso nicht aber glaubt
verarschen und sie wollen uns verarschen
während ricky the stars hey ich glaub
ich weiß wie ich das mache und zwar so
ein richtig simplen trick und zwar gibt
es ja diese es gibt ja die möglichkeit
dass man so diesen redstone fackel
elevator macht weiß was meine red storm
fackel elevator ja das ist nicht
gelagert das ist richtig jetzt mache ich
das mal so da kommt die sahne kraut ihn
bauen da kommt ihr direkt mein gott ich
habe zwei hat kennt ist da wo soll ich
hin packen rechtsklick im winter so
diese nicht da
doch jetzt um ein goldkäfer zusatz
herzen begeben und die gerade noch drauf
der mega cool aus orange richtig geile
besser leben rief aber wir haben den
ordentlich angst gemacht
kollateralschaden wurde von dir begangen
das heißt wenn der lärm entsteht leute
es kommt wie es kommen alle zu mir ja
besser leben genau könnte ich habe
gehört das ist das allerbeste leben
kommt alle zu melden
richtig schön das möchte ich auch noch
mal betonen also wenn ihr überhaupt
etwas kostet dann windows and muss hält
sein also er muss einfach hält sein
genau sondern sind
lösche ich das wenn es kein held sie
sind extra so das kann man noch
einstellen bei youtube das heißt man
sagen okay ich will hält haben dann
sogar normale kommentare gehen
mindestens einmal hut und sohn enthalten
wenn die rag gesperrt dann für immer
gesperrt
ich werde dich jetzt nur wegen dieser
fake aussage komme ich schon richtig
viele hunde suchen sonst aber echt böses
wort ja ich war ich finde das auch kacke
eigentlich dass das mittlerweile so
inflationär genutzt wird
aber obwohl ich das kranke vielleicht
wenn er sagt ja es wird einfach in 90
minuten so oder so dann wird jetzt ganz
zeit zu produkten eigentlich finde ich
dass kaka aber irgendwie habe ich das
jetzt auch übernommen und deswegen kann
ich nicht mehr meckern
ja da sorgt gleich verschiedene deine
meinung
aus welchem holz habe dass er noch
gebauten häuser ich finde es irgendwie
nicht schön den was den stil für unser
staat sollte so ein bisschen schöner
werden ich bin jetzt gespannt ob das
hier klappt so etwas kleines gebaut
da bin ich echt gespannt
spieler der experte eriks wie baue ich
das dann wünschen wir keinen plan und
das auch so doof eingekreuzt mit diesem
holz hier die frage gestellt vorbei ich
hab nix geschafft nichts wirklich nichts
hier kann ich das jetzt einfach so dahin
testen erst mal ob das geht damit dass
wenigstens im untergrund ist der ein-
und ausschalter kommt beim nächsten mal
ein beispiel es wenigstens überhaupt
irgendetwas abliefern 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 2
3 4
so jetzt kommt hier diese so was haben
wir aber das bringt dich sie schon mal
ist leuchtet hier an der seite
denn sofort da ja hallo
wieso kann ich den blog nicht setzen
block den holzblock tiefe den rhein
sitzen die passagiere weil ich das mal
so und so sagt das eigentlich
funktionieren aber wieso tut das nicht
das weiß nur der liebe gott
es geht wirklich nicht kommt auch noch
einer hin dass zu viel jetzt noch also
irgendwie und jetzt auch ich weiß nicht
da nie eine tür ein und ja es geht gut
genau so dass nur so eine kleine lücke
dann drin
hier kommt dann die tür was ja wie
findest du das
das kann weg und hier ist einfach nur so
da die lücke drin und das war eine
komplette konstruktion jetzt in kleinen
quasi genau das was ich hatte in klein
aber das ist unten hier und da will ich
jetzt noch in schalter man also nur
unten bist ein schalter der sozusagen wo
man einschalten kann oder nein oder sagt
nein ich noch nicht
schalten oder nein genau davon beim
hierhin des elternrates zufolge zu ende
ich auch diese blöden halben teile habe
ich dir dann hingewiesen hatte dass ich
weiß nie wo ich ihnen was hinwerfe
vergleich aus ganz simpel einschalten
oder nein so schreibe ich das auch
einschalten nur dann einschalten
einschalten oder ja leute ich weiß nicht
wie sand bauen soll
kannst du erkennen wo du den stabilen
scheitert drehen müsstest um
einzuschalten
naja so wie jetzt ist er sogar an das
einschalten
es sei nicht geschrieben oder das
umsetzen kann so viel ich habe gar keine
fragen beantwortet nur eine automarke
mensch das ist eine traurige und sind 53
fragen noch an ohne frage sex bei der
jugend ja aber man sollte nicht jugend
sein und das sollen beide partner
einverstanden sein
ja ich bin ein glücklicher youtuber also
noch die frage ob es fragen alter sagt
einfach [ __ ] okay das nicht schlimm
ich glaube ich lass es einfach so und
dann denke ich dass red dawn sachen
runter sagt einfach [ __ ] zu mir ja
ich glaube so mache ich das so freunde
dann würde ich sagen das war es mit
dieser folge
wenn es euch gefallen hat lass deine
bewertung da bin ich dann auch gefallen
hat und ihr könnt uns ja in die
kommentare einfach mal schreiben was
würdet ihr machen wenn ihr youtube
machen würde und dann auf einmal einen
heftigen unfall habt so ist es also
leute wir sehen uns einer nächsten folge
bleibt geil macht's gut bis dahin conny
vergisst man hingeht so macht es dann
los